deux ans après la disparition à
guermantes de la petite estelle neuf ans
un arbre du souvenir a été planté tout
près de l'endroit où la fillette a été
aperçue pour la dernière fois deux ans
dans lequel tous azimuts les malgré des
opérations de très grande ampleur
aucune piste sérieuse est toujours la
ténacité du père d'estelle qui refusent
de baisser les bras ni koné luizet annie
tri boire un arbre symbole d'espoir
plantées à proximité du lieu où est elle
a été aperçue pour la dernière fois
c'était ici à guermantes
il y a déjà deux ans depuis le premier
instant je me suis dit que beaucoup de
mon énergie seraient consacrés à ça et
j'essaye de tenir le cap et de ne pas
perdre une peine dissipées et arriver au
résultat
comme lui tous espèrent ici qu'un jour
cette disparition sera élucidée en
silence
des centaines de personnes sont venues
apporter leur soutien à la famille pour
questel ne soit pas oublié j'espère que
malgré tout il soutient continuera aux
familles et qu elle l enquête ne
s'arrêterait pas là on peut pas rester
indifférent
c'est effectivement un moment fort qui
malheureusement se répète tous les tous
les ans depuis des années et on aimerait
bien que ça soit ça s'arrête
un peu plus tôt dans l'après midi aux
côtés de la famille le directeur du srpj
de versailles a tenu à faire le point
sur l'enquêté
après deux ans donc c'est d'abord la
piste locale on ne vient pas enlever une
petite fille de cet âge de 9 ans a entre
qui sort de l'école alors qu'il fait
moins neuf degrés alors qu'il ya du
verglas et que les conditions de
circulation sont extrêmement difficiles
c'est le 9 janvier 2003 estelle mouzin
disparaissent sur le chemin du retour de
l'école
très vite des recherches sont
entreprises
un portrait robot diffusé mais la
fillette reste introuvable
tout a été tenté affichage site internet
répondeur téléphonique en vain en mai
dernier six suspects sont interpellés
puis mis hors de cause
pour la famille d'estelle 24 mois de
faux espoirs partout en france journée
nationale de dépistage de l'obésité
infantile une maladie en constante
progression
la france sur nous